[Musik]
>> SALLY & MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Hallo!
>> SALLY & MURAT: Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Lass doch.
>> MURAT: Nein! Nein, hör auf damit!
>> SALLY: Das ist doch süß!
>> MURAT: Nein, das machen wir jetzt nicht. Hör zu.
Folgendes:
Es ist Silvester.
Ja.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es ein Silvester,
was wir noch nie hatten.
>> MURAT: Richtig? >> SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
>> MURAT: So. Ich möchte euch gar nicht die Laune verderben.
Weil die darf man sich nicht verderben lassen, weil man muss
>> SALLY: Ja, das stimmt.
>> MURAT: auch lachen können.
>> SALLY: Das Jahr war besonders,
aber davon lassen wir uns nicht unterkriegen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der Murat hat mir eine Challenge gestellt.
>> MURAT: Ich habe einfach einen Wunsch gehabt, okay?
Und zwar
>> SALLY: Es ist eine Challenge.
>> MURAT: Folgendes: Ich hatte im Traum einfach
einen großen Big Mac, also einen ganz großen,
also einer, wo ich wirklich
– wo ich ganz lange was essen...
>> SALLY: Du hättest gern einfach mal
>> MURAT & Sally: einen großen Big Mac.
>> MURAT: So. Okay, jetzt ist es raus.
Einfach einen großen Big Mac. So.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Und meine Frau soll mir jetzt
einfach einen Riesen-Big-Mac machen.
Es ist ein cooles Ding für Silvester.
Es ist ein Crowdfeeder.
>> SALLY: Aber dieses Jahr gibt es keine Crowd.
>> MURAT: Aber diesmal gibt es keine Crowd.
Das heißt, es...
>> SALLY: Es gibt nur dich und mich und die Kids
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: und unser Team.
Das heißt, feiert Silvester
>> SALLY: Aber nicht an Silvester.
>> MURAT: mit Freunden
>> SALLY: Nicht.
>> MURAT: nicht.
>> SALLY: Ach! Es geht einfach darum:
Murat möchte, dass ich einen Riesen-Big-Mac mache.
Den mache ich jetzt.
Mein Gott!
Es wird jetzt auch keiner so.
Also ich bin ja jetzt nicht Jumbo von Galileo
und mache jetzt hier den 5-Meter-Durchmesser-Big-Mac,
sondern ich mache das so,
dass es in Haushaltsgröße stattfindet.
Ich gebe mein Bestes.
>> MURAT: Ja. Zu Testzwecken
werde ich mir jetzt drei Big Mac holen.
Richtig? Drei?
>> SALLY: Ich habe zwei bestellt
>> MURAT: Zwei?
>> SALLY: zu Testzwecken.
>> MURAT: Okay. Also dann hole ich jetzt kurz
>> SALLY: Nicht noch einen für dich.
>> MURAT: drei für Testzwecke.
Und danach machst du den Großen, okay?
>> SALLY: Also ich habe mir gedacht,
ich mache jetzt einfach meine Burgerbrötchen.
Dafür gibt es ja auch schon ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal.
>> MURAT: Also der fleischgewordene Traum
von Männern.
>> SALLY: Du hast da noch ein bisschen Schlafsand
in den Augen.
>> MURAT: Okay. Ich gehe jetzt zu McDonald's.
Und Bye Bye.
>> SALLY: Du hast da noch Schlafsand.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und ich mache jetzt meinen Burger-Bun-Rezept
aus einem Kilo Mehl.
Ich denke, ich brauche nur die Hälfte,
aber ich mache lieber
– zur Sicherheit mache ich mal viele.
Okay.
Das Rezept findet ihr schon auf dem Kanal,
aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem kurz.
Ich brauche dafür einen Würfel Hefe,
200 Gramm warmes Wasser,
jeweils 30 Gramm Zuckerrübensirup und Zucker,
zwei Eier.
Hier habe ich etwas Milch,
ein Kilo Mehl,
– da könnte Dinkel oder Weizen nehmen –
zwei Esslöffel Salz
und 160 Gramm Butter.
Was ihr zuerst macht, ist
die Hefe im Wasser auflösen.
Dann kommt der Zuckerrübensirup dazu.
Stattdessen könnt ihr auch Honig benutzen.
Der bringt aber auch eine schöne Farbe mit rein,
muss man sagen, und einen guten Geschmack.
Etwas Zucker.
Und dann könnt ihr jetzt alle Zutaten reingeben.
Die Butter auf jeden Fall noch schmelzen oder halt erwärmen.
[Musik]
Und hier gebe ich immer erst mal einen Teil des Mehls dazu.
Die Eier.
Und das Salz.
Und das Salz immer nicht direkt auf die Hefe.
Denn die Hefe mag Salz nicht so gerne.
Und die Milch.
Die darf auch gerne warm sein,
lauwarm oder handwarm.
Jetzt kurz verkneten
und dann gebe ich noch die flüssige Butter dazu
und das restliche Mehl,
damit eben ein schöner, geschmeidiger Teig entsteht.
Und den verknetet ihr dann für etwa zehn Minuten.
Das passt dann ganz gut.
[Musik]
So. Der Teig ist jetzt fertig.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Du warst aber schnell, du.
>> MURAT: Drei
Big Mac.
>> SALLY: Und wie viele hast du gekauft? Drei oder...
>> MURAT: Wirklich drei Stück.
>> SALLY: Wirklich? Keinen gegessen?
>> MURAT: Nein, wirklich nicht.
Ich hatte keine Zeit.
>> SALLY: Oh, wow! Wenn er schon so quer drin steht,
weiß ich, wie er aussieht.
Mh. Geht aber.
Also die
nehmen wir später zu...
Ich schaue sie mir später an.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Okay.
Hier ist der Teig fertig.
Ich schabe immer ganz gerne
den Rand so ein bisschen runter.
Und dann kann ich ihn abdecken.
Ich würde ihn jetzt eigentlich darin aufgehen lassen,
mache ich auch gleich.
Oder im Backofen bei Gärstufe geht auch
oder einfach an einem warmen Ort in der Küche.
Ich stelle den kurz zur Seite.
Denn
jetzt kommt das
– oh, da habe ich die Servietten.
Jetzt kommt das Fleisch-Patty dran.
Da habe ich mir jetzt viele Gedanken gemacht zwischendrin
und muss sagen
– normalerweise mache ich es so bei Rindfleisch-Pattys,
dass ich einfach nur Fleisch nehme,
auch nicht salze, nicht würze
und wirklich schön forme, anbrate
und danach wird es gewürzt mit der Grillsoße.
Jetzt ist es ja ein XXL-Burger und der wird ja recht groß.
Und der muss ja auch eine gewisse Stabilität haben.
Und ich denke, ich mache es jetzt hier so:
Ich nehme einfach Hackfleisch.
Da habe ich jetzt mal 2,8 Kilo für zwei Stück.
Ich habe auch gerade gesehen, es sind zwei.
Ich nehme Eier für die Bindung, damit mir das Patty
– der oder das? –
>> JOSH: Das.
>> SALLY: das Patty
beim Wenden nicht auseinanderfällt,
ein bisschen Semmelbrösel,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Ja, ich denke,
das wird schon, wird.
Ihr könnt das jetzt mit den Händen verkneten
oder auch mit der Küchenmaschine.
Ja, das wird irgendwie.
Ich gebe jetzt einfach mal die Zutaten so rein,
wie ich sie mir abgewogen habe.
Und falls ich noch was daran verändere,
schreibe ich es euch einfach in die App rein,
in den Blog rein, ins Rezept rein.
Und jetzt mal das Salz, einen Esslöffel,
und Pfeffer.
Ihr könnt auch Rauchsalz benutzen, wenn ihr möchtet.
Dann habt ihr schon mal so ein rauchiges Aroma mit dabei.
Ist bestimmt auch nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Und schön verkneten.
Ich denke, so ist es ganz gut.
Ich werde jetzt noch testen,
ob Salz- und Pfeffergehalt stimmen.
Ich probiere das aber nicht roh, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Ich mache das dann so:
Ich mache so eine Minifrikadelle
und brate sie entweder in der Pfanne kurz an
oder in der Mikrowelle.
Hauptsache, sie ist durch und ich kann probieren,
ob die Gewürze stimmen.
Das ist ein Backofen und eine Mikrowelle,
falls ihr euch wundert.
[Musik]
Ja.
Ist gut.
Dann
werde ich jetzt mein XXL-Patty formen.
Ich mache das jetzt so:
Der Burger Bun, den werde ich hier drin backen
im Emailleblech.
Dann habe ich einfach schon mal eine runde Form
in diesem Pizzablech.
Der Patty muss ein bisschen größer sein.
Denn der zieht sich ja beim Backen zusammen.
Und ich erzähle euch gleich,
wie und worauf ich das ausbacken werde.
Also zuerst mal
– o Gott, ist das schwer!
Ojemine!
Zuerst mal halbieren.
[Musik]
Dann das Blech so ein bisschen einsprühen mit Fett.
Und jetzt hier ein Patty formen.
Vielleicht mit so einer Burgerpresse noch flach drücken
oder mit einem anderen flachen Gegenstand.
Eine Pfanne geht auch.
Oder einfach ein zweites Blech drauf.
Dann
gebe ich es hier auf so eine Folie.
Ihr könnt auch Backpapier nehmen.
Einmal am Rand ein bisschen lösen und dann
fällt es von alleine runter.
Aber ich muss es ja jetzt noch ein bisschen größer machen,
so ein paar Zentimeter.
Also noch leicht flach drücken.
So forme ich auch gleich den zweiten.
Die müssen jetzt natürlich eingefroren werden
und später ausgebacken werden.
Ich habe keine Pfanne, die so groß ist,
und auch keine Grillplatte, die so groß ist.
Ihr vielleicht auch nicht.
Vielleicht habt ihr eine.
Also, falls ihr es draußen auf dem Grill zubereitet,
könnt ihr das so gern draußen auf
irgendwas grillen.
Ich mache es jetzt allerdings so:
Ich werde es jetzt halbieren
und werde später vier Hälften anbraten.
Und so kann ich es dann auch einfrieren
mit dem Alublech hier.
Wie ziehe ich das hier runter?
Das überlege ich mir noch schnell.
So.
Und dann einfrieren, bis sie schön fest sind.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Wow, wow, wow!
Ich glaube, dann werden wir gleich
mal die Burger untersuchen, damit ich weiß,
wie ich weitermache mit Soße und so weiter.
Und hier mache ich es so
– ich habe jetzt auch nicht unendlich Platz im Gefrierfach.
Ich stelle jetzt hier einfach drei Schälchen hin,
die so ein bisschen eine Höhe haben.
Und dann kann ich die Bleche übereinanderstapeln.
So mache ich das.
[Musik]
Machen wir die Big-Mac-Analyse.
>> MURAT: Ja, Analyse.
So.
Darf ich kurz?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
So.
>> SALLY: Du, es war dein Wunschrezept.
Dann mach es.
>> MURAT: So.
Also jetzt nehmen wir den mal auseinander.
So, weg.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Fangen wir an, okay?
Natürlich das Brötchen. Okay?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das Brötchen ist
>> SALLY: weich.
>> MURAT: ist weich.
Warte. Ich esse mal nur mit Brötchen.
[Zeitraffer]
Drei Tage später...
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Kalt schmeckt der gar nicht.
Ehrlich.
Der schmeckt kalt gar nicht.
Ich würde den nicht essen kalt.
Mhm.
>> SALLY: Weiter geht es jetzt also mit der Soße.
Dafür verwende ich
eine Zwiebel,
Essiggurken
und ein bisschen Essiggurkenwasser habe ich hier noch drin,
400 Gramm Mayonnaise,
etwas Essig,
Tomatenmark,
Senf,
Salz
und Pfeffer.
Gut. Die Zwiebel habe ich jetzt bereits geschält.
Die wird fein gewürfelt.
Hier muss ich dazu sagen:
Die Mayonnaise könnt ihr ganz einfach selber machen
mit Eigelb, etwas Essig, Salz, Pfeffer und Öl.
Da gibt es auch schon ganz viele Rezepte auf meinem Kanal.
Also da könnt ihr einfach eingeben "Mayonnaise Sally"
oder "Mayonnaise" in meiner App eingeben.
Da findet ihr das Rezept.
Und davon braucht ihr dann 400 Gramm.
[Musik]
Die kommen hier jetzt direkt mit zur Soße.
Dann die Essiggurken auch fein würfeln.
Das, muss ich sagen, hat mir echt gut geschmeckt,
dass man da so ein bisschen den Biss hat von den Gürkchen.
Das mag ich nämlich echt gerne.
Und da kommt ja auch die Süße her,
weil in Essiggurken halt echt viel Zucker steckt,
muss ich sagen.
Deswegen schmecken die so süßlich.
Das Wasser auch direkt mit rein.
Dann kommen jetzt noch die restlichen Zutaten mit rein:
Essig für die Säure,
Tomatenmark ein bisschen auch für die Farbe,
muss ich sagen,
damit das Ganze so ein bisschen einen rötlicheren Stich hat,
etwas Senf
und Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Und dann verrühren.
Okay, XXL-Burger,
da nehmen wir auch einen XXL-Schneebesen.
Da komme ich  mit dem kleinen jetzt nicht weit.
[Musik]
Möchtest du mal probieren?
>> JOSH: Ja, gerne.
Würdest du jetzt auch Nein sagen,
wenn ich dich vor der Kamera frage?
So: "Nö, will ich nicht probieren"?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Aber
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: die ist echt lecker.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Richtig schön würzig.
>> JOSH: Auch so ein bisschen pikant von den Gürkchen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Pfeffer?
>> SALLY: Pfeffer.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die stelle ich jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann forme ich die Burgerbrötchen.
Oh, ich muss was trinken.
Ja. Jetzt machen wir mal ein
Burgerbrötchen XXL.
Also
ich werde zwei Optionen testen.
Denn ich will ja auch, dass es gut aussieht.
Ich will ja, dass es perfekt aussieht.
Also hier ist mein Teig.
Okay.
Ich probiere es einfach.
Das Problem oder die Herausforderung,
nicht ein Problem, die Herausforderung ist ja,
dass ja der Burger sozusagen in drei Teile geschnitten wird.
Also zweimal muss ich ihn durchschneiden können.
Und vom Durchmesser her
muss er eben auch recht groß sein,
also mindestens so groß wie das Pizzablech.
Und jetzt mache ich es einfach so,
dass ich den rund forme.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt mal hier ein 32er Blech
und fette das gut.
Ich mache da ja auch gerne mal Buchteln oder Focaccia drin.
Ich bin mir, glaube ich, gerade fast sicher,
dass ich den kompletten Teig da einfach reinmache.
Und ich setze jetzt alles auf eine Karte.
[Grillenzirpen]
Oder ich lasse ihn erst aufgehen und lege ihn dann.
Aber dann ist halt die Gefahr,
dass er halt wieder so zusammenfällt.
Hu!
Weil so ist er mir jetzt echt noch zu klein.
Komm, no risk, no fun, oder?
Ich mache es so:
Ich lasse den jetzt so noch mal kurz aufgehen und ruhen.
Dann lässt er sich nämlich einfacher in Form bringen.
Einfach entweder jetzt abdecken
oder noch mal im Ofen bei Gärstufe,
damit er noch mal schön locker wird.
Und dann werde ich ihn da drin backen.
Ihr könnt ihn aber auch ganz frei auf einem Blech backen.
Also ihr könnt jetzt sozusagen den Burger in Form bringen,
ein bisschen flach rollen,
aber auch vorher kurz jetzt noch mal
so aufgehen lassen als Kugel.
Und dann wird das schon.
Ich habe es im Gefühl.
[Musik]
Also ich bin eher der Fan von Zwiebelringen
auf dem Burger.
Du?
>> JOSH: Auch Zwiebelringe. Ja, ja.
>> SALLY: Gell? Also das ist für mich eigentlich gerade so,
wie ich es gerne nicht machen würde,
aber ich will es ja jetzt originalgetreu machen.
Ich mache es jetzt mal.
Aber ich persönlich würde jetzt beim XXL-Burger
Zwiebelringe machen,
rote Zwiebelringe.
Mmh!
Die sind zum einen verträglicher
und zum anderen finde ich sie halt auch leckerer.
Aber komm. Ich will jetzt keinen Hate vom Murat.
Der will es immer so richtig originalgetreu.
Und beim Salat nehme ich jetzt hier
auch einfach so einen Eisbergsalat.
Ich habe den gewaschen.
Kurz schleudern.
[Musik]
So sieht er jetzt aus.
Okay.
Aber ich backe es hier drin.
Wie gesagt, gefettet ist es schon.
Ich glaube, ich nehme nur noch ein bisschen
für den Rand auch.
Puh!
Das Problem ist, dass meine Hände gerade so fettig sind,
dass die Folie die ganze Zeit unter meiner Hand wegrutscht.
[Musik]
So. Und wenn der dann darin so schön backt,
müsste ich drei Schichten rausschneiden können.
Was ich jetzt hier noch mache, ist Folgendes:
Ein bisschen Eigelb mit Wasser habe ich schon verquirlt.
Das wird jetzt hier draufgestrichen,
sorgt auch für die Bräune.
Jetzt nur nicht zu viel draufstreichen,
damit hier unten diese Eiermasse
nicht an der Ofenform dann festklebt sozusagen.
Und dann Sesam.
Eigentlich wird das jetzt so ein gigantisches Fladenbrot, nicht?
Nein, es wird ein schönes Brötchen.
Komm.
Du wirst wunderschön!
Was ich jetzt machen werde:
Ich werde es jetzt direkt im heißen Ofen backen.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits vorgeheizt.
Lieber weiter unten backen,
damit es nicht ganz so dunkel wird direkt.
Passt, oder?
Und guck mal.
Da ist sogar schon richtig der Boden gelöst.
Hat perfekt geklappt!
O mein Gott!
Ich nehme es jetzt hier raus auf ein Abkühlgitter,
damit es von unten jetzt nicht schwitzt,
also dass es auch wirklich brötchenmäßig
schön trocken auch am Boden bleibt.
Ui, ui, ui!
Komm, die Frauen kennen doch das Problem, oder?
Dass man was anbrät
und man hat echt so frisch gewaschene Haare.
Und dann hasst man es einfach.
Ich wasche jetzt meine Haare nicht noch mal.
Aber ich muss jetzt den Burger anbraten
und es wird stinken
und ich will meine Haare jetzt danach...
Mein Gott! Das kennen nur Frauen, das Problem.
>> SARAH: Das kennen echt nur Frauen.
>> SALLY: Deswegen, entweder du setzt jetzt ein Kopftuch auf
– so habe ich es immer gemacht –
oder eine Mütze oder eine Perücke.
Ich habe jetzt leider nur eine Perücke hier zur Hand.
>> SARAH: So.
>> SALLY: Danke!
Es stinkt zwar dann danach die Perücke,
aber das macht nichts.
Die können wir lüften.
Jetzt kann ich den Burger anbraten,
ohne dass meine Haare stinken.
Es reicht, wenn ich danach die Jeans waschen muss, weißt.
Also
jetzt wird angebraten.
Ich weiß, es sieht bescheuert aus.
Aber es geht jetzt gerade nicht anders.
Ich habe morgen echt einen wichtigen Termin.
Da will ich mir Locken machen.
Und Locken mit frisch gewaschenen Haaren
sind immer schwieriger.
Wie gesagt, Frauenprobleme.
Okay.
Ich werde das jetzt hier auf der Grillplatte anbraten
mit etwas Öl
und werde sie dann im Backofen fertig garen.
Aber hier bekommen sie jetzt einfach mal schön Röstaromen.
Jetzt machen wir hier die Lüftung auf volle Pulle
und dann wird es schon schiefgehen mit den Haaren.
Jetzt von beiden Seiten scharf anbraten.
Und dann gebe ich es in den Backofen,
damit das ihnen schön durch ist,
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
mein Burgerbrötchen durchschneiden.
Und ich wende es zuerst,
wenn es wirklich eine schöne Röstung unten hat,
damit es eben nicht zerfällt.
Also einfach jetzt liegen lassen.
Also wir probieren, das jetzt mal hier
mit der Tortensäge zu schneiden.
Das wäre schon cool.
Nee.
Aber vielleicht, wenn ich es einschneide.
Denn Hefeteig hat eine andere Struktur als Biskuit.
Mh. Schwierig.
Dann machen wir es mit Abstandshölzern.
Ui!
Es ist noch ein bisschen zu warm geschnitten.
Ups!
Ich lasse es mal ein bisschen abkühlen.
Und dann schneide ich es noch mal durch.
Aber ich hätte es abkühlen lassen müssen.
Aber es macht jetzt nichts.
[Musik]
Also ich brate die jetzt noch kurz fertig.
Die Pattys sind
– nee ein bisschen tue ich sie noch in den Backofen.
Zum einen bleiben sie warm
und zum anderen garen sie durch.
Und dann wird belegt.
Ich musste jetzt erst mal nebenher noch Sellerie essen
bei so viel Fleisch und Brot.
Also das Fleisch habe ich jetzt hier im Backofen.
Das darf noch ein bisschen durchziehen.
Was ich jetzt aber machen werde
– ich weiß, das ist dann nicht mehr original Big Mac,
aber ich muss dazusagen:
Beim Big Mac in der Großproduktion ist es ja auch so,
es muss ja auch schnell zu machen sein und einfach sein.
Deswegen ja auch die Zwiebelwürfel und keine Ringe,
weil Würfel kann man einfach schmeißen,
Ringe muss man sorgfältig legen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier noch das Restfett, was hier drin ist,
und brate die Zwiebelwürfel an.
Ein paar behalte ich mal noch
zum Draufstreuen für die Deko.
Dann hat man nämlich einen richtig schönen Geschmack.
[Musik]
Also dann wird jetzt hier der XXL-Burger zusammengebaut.
Ich habe die Perücke noch auf.
Denn es riecht hier noch ordentlich nach Frittenbude.
Hach!
So.
Brötchen.
Dann kommt Soße.
Ich habe hier meine Zeichnung.
Ich werde mich exakt am Big Mac orientieren.
Brötchen.
Oh, warte, warte!
Da ich das Brötchen nicht grillen kann,
– ich habe ja jetzt nicht so eine große Grillplatte –
werde ich es ansmoken.
Ich meine: Why not?
Ob jetzt da der Grill oder hier das Feuer,
Hauptsache, Röstaromen.
Oder?
Da steht die Verrückte in ihrer Küche
mit dem Bunsenbrenner und einem XXL-Burger.
Okay, und einer Perücke.
[Musik]
Dann kommt
Soße.
Soße ist Gelb.
Und die Soße ist recht würzig.
Die sollte auch sehr würzig sein.
Denn Salat und Käse und Gürkchen und so weiter,
die habe ich ja nicht gewürzt.
Das ist ja praktisch so alles on top.
Und das Fleisch ist jetzt auch nicht überwürzt.
Daher darf die Soße ruhig ein bisschen würzig sein.
Okay.
Salat.
Beim Salat, wie gesagt, ich mache jetzt keine
Streifen, sondern ich lege das jetzt so drauf.
Käse.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einen Cheddar.
[Musik]
Dann kommt jetzt
das Fleisch.
Yummy!
Lachst du gerade über den Burger oder über mich?
>> SARAH: Ich lache einfach über den Burger.
>> SALLY: Über die Situation.
>> SARAH: Ja, über die.
>> SALLY: Puh!
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt wieder Brot,
der Mittelteil.
Sieht das gut aus?
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ich sage mal Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann Soße.
[Musik]
Also bei der Soße habe ich jetzt echt
ein bisschen nur was übrig.
Das lasse ich jetzt auch.
Sonst wird es, glaube ich, echt zu heftig.
Aber da kann man ja wunderschön
auch Pommes reintunken.
Soße.
Jetzt die Zwiebel.
[Musik]
Da gebe ich jetzt noch rohe Zwiebeln drauf,
einfach so noch außenrum,
weil es einfach die Originalität widerspiegelt.
Soße, Zwiebeln, Salat.
[Musik]
Ich haue mal so viel Salat rein wie möglich,
so als Füllmittel,
damit die Kinder viel Salat essen.
Auch so Murat.
Wo sind eigentlich die Gürkchen?
Ah, die sind jetzt obendrauf.
So.
Dann die zwei McDonald's-Gürkchen.
Eins
– warte, warte! Die müssen hier so rausgucken.
Fertig.
Kommt schon.
Hey, da dürfte ihr echt nicht so geizig sein.
Haut die Gewürzgurken da drauf!
[Musik]
Ich glaube, spätestens jetzt sagen alle:
"Okay, wo kann man bei euch als Verkoster arbeiten?"
Patty.
Brötchen.
Bereit?
>> JOSH: Bereit.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Murat hat mich herausgefordert.
Er wollte einen XXL Big Mac.
Da hat er ihn.
[Musik]
Eines muss ich dazu sagen:
Murat ist leider nicht mehr da.
Der ist jetzt auf einem Termin.
Aber die Kids dürfen jetzt Burger essen.
Ela, warte, warte.
Stell dich mal kurz da hoch.
Ich ,mache – warte, warte!
Bleib mal bei mir.
Ich will dir was sagen.
Samira, dreh dich
– halt!
Nein, warte.
Guck zu mir. Guck zu mir.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist...
>> SALLY: Guck zu mir! Hallo!
>> SAMIRA: Ich gucke zu dir.
>> SALLY: Ihr guckt jetzt beide zu mir.
Und eines muss ich sagen, Ela:
Ich habe für uns was zu essen gemacht,
aber leider nur eine Portion.
Ich habe leider nur eins. Das müsst ihr euch teilen.
Ist das okay?
>> ELA: Das ist doch...
Ich glaube, das ist riesig.
Hast du schon gespickt?
Dreht euch mal um.
>> SAMIRA: Boah!
>> ELA: Wie hast du das gemacht?!
>> SALLY: Ich habe gezaubert.
>> ELA: Du kannst nicht zaubern.
>> SALLY: Doch.
Krass, oder?
Der war so klein.
Und dann habe ich Schnippe di Schwipp, fupp, fupp gemacht
und dann Abrakadabra
und dann war er groß.
Krass, oder?
>> ELA: Ah!
>> SAMIRA: Aber der Burger Patty ist auch ganz groß!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also cool, oder?
Jetzt schneiden wir den an und essen den.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Kriegst du den leer, Ela?
>> ELA: Nee.
>> SAMIRA: Also ich ja. Ich habe Bärenhunger!
>> ELA: Ich auch. Ich habe auch Bärenhunger.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss dazu sagen:
Diese Portion ist jetzt so groß wie 24 Einzelburger,
also von meinen Burgern.
Halt! Nicht abmachen!
Ja, 24 Einzelburger.
Okay.
Kommt, wir verhungern doch schon alle, ja?
>> SAMIRA: Das Messer ist ja...
>> SALLY: Ja, Samira, wir tauschen ganz kurz die Plätze.
>> SAMIRA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Dann kann ich von hier anschneiden.
>> SAMIRA: Ist der Käse eigentlich schon angeschmolzen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Es sieht ein bisschen...
Oh!
>> ELA: Da will ich das erste Stück!
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Guck mal, wie groß das ist!
>> SALLY: Boah!
>> SAMIRA: O mein Gott!
Wieso läuft da Wasser runter?
>> SALLY: Das ist die Soße.
Das ist halt...
Boah, das ist echt krass!
Das ist wirklich krass!
>> SAMIRA: Das ist ja größer als ein Burger!
>> SALLY: Wie sollen wir das jetzt essen?
Eigentlich mit Gabel und Messer, nicht?
Kommt, Mädels, ihr dürft jetzt probieren
>> SAMIRA: Das ist echt...
>> SALLY: den Riesen-XXL-Burger.
Soll ich den mal so runternehmen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Ist das ein Big Mac?
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Ich schneide es
mal mit dem Damastmesser.
Okay. Ela, hier, ein Stück.
>> ELA: Mhm. Ich nehme das.
>> SALLY: Da.
Ich habe es doch schon für dich.
>> ELA: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Oder, Samira, hier.
Komm, ich helfe dir beim Schneiden.
>> ELA: Entschuldigung. Das war...
Okay.
>> SALLY: Da müssen wir Papa halt ein Stück aufheben.
Den dürfen wir nicht komplett aufessen.
Okay, einmal probieren.
Mmh!
Hm.
>> ELA: Mh!
>> SALLY: War das Stück zu groß, gell?
Boah!
Der schmeckt echt richtig gut!
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
Was sagst du, Ela,
als Burgerexpertin?
Was sagst du, Samira, als Burgerexpertin?
Und ich als Burgerexpertin
sage, er schmeckt richtig gut.
Also probiert das Rezept gerne mal aus.
Ich bin mega begeistert, dass es geklappt hat,
und auch sehr erleichtert, muss ich sagen.
Denn
ich muss sagen, so schön habe ich mir ihn nicht vorgestellt.
Also ich habe schon gedacht, er wird ganz cool.
Aber, dass er so schön wird,
hätte ich jetzt auch nicht gedacht.
Also kommt, Mädels. Wir setzen uns an den Tisch
und essen jetzt in Ruhe den Burger, okay?
>> SAMIRA & ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Na los!
>> ELA: Aber...
>> SALLY: Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Und falls ihr auch eine XXL-Challenge für mich habt,
schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich bin schon gespannt drauf.
Man kann ja wirklich alles in XXL zubereiten.
Manchmal ist es einfacher als die kleine Portion,
aber manchmal ist es auch richtig schwierig.
Von daher tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Ela, und wo gibt es das Rezept?
Auf
>> ELA: Sallys Blog.
>> SALLY: Sallys Blog und in der
>> SAMIRA: App.
>> SALLY: Genau.
Tschüss!
Nimm du mal das. Ich trage den Burger.
Denn der ist richtig schwer.
>> SAMIRA: Können wir es nicht andersrum?
>> SALLY: O Gott!
[Musik]